the astroworld festival was launched
three years ago as a tribute to a
popular theme park in the texan city of
houston and has grown in popularity
since
last year's event was cancelled because
of culvert so all 50 000 tickets for
this were snapped up in the space of an
hour when they went on sale in may
the rapper travis scott who founded the
festival and is from houston stopped
several times during his 75-minute set
when he spotted fans in distress we need
somebody to help him somebody passed out
right here
somebody passed out right here hold on
don't touch him don't touch him
everybody just back up
security somebody help jump in real
quick keep going but panic later set in
and the crowd surged towards the front
of the stage it's not yet known what
caused the incident my job as a chief of
police is to make sure that we find out
what happened
we will treat
it as an investigation because we don't
know
i have investigators out here on the
scene i'm sending investigators to the
home i mean to the hospitals
because we just don't know
and we will find out the on-site medical
team was quickly overwhelmed by hundreds
of casualties emergency vehicles trying
to access the most seriously injured
appeared to be hindered by revelers
unaware of what was unfolding once we
started having the mass casualty
incident where people were starting uh
we started having cpr on several people
and it happened all at once suddenly we
had several people down on the ground
experience some type of cardiac arrest
or some type of
medical episode
and so we have been we immediately
started doing cpr and moving people
right then
earlier in the day hundreds of people
had rushed the perimeter fence to gain
access
the second and final day of the event
has now been cancelled as police begin
their investigation and de brady sky
news